any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
welcome everybody to the latest edition
of the into the impossible podcast
today is a special episode for me
because i get to interview one of my
heroes in astronomy on the eve of his
birthday it's not actually his birthday
but i dressed up nonetheless i was going
to have a party hat
but i decided against that because i'm
already having a bad enough hair day as
it is
today's guest is uh none other than dr
david spurgle
who uh i've known for many many years
his legends are
numerous plentiful and well deserved i
describe him
whenever i'm given the honor of
introducing him
at a talk or a speech of any kind i
always say he's astronomy's
chuck yeager because as you guys know
i'm a pilot
and whenever i'm putting around in my
little tiny cessna
i will get um the chance to talk to air
traffic control
and every pilot no matter the tiniest
plane whatsoever
will channel chuck yeager we're gonna go
take off and run with six three and take
down and go
southbound and take it and then you just
channel it with that with that drawl
and then air traffic control you may not
know this they have to treat you like
your chuck yeager
even if you're doing you know a whopping
75 knots so
that's a cessna 16 i don't know it's
good to see you today you know you're
clear through class problems
and i just feel when i'm doing that i'm
chuck yeager and i feel
that like chuck yeager every astronomer
wants to be you in one way or another
you are such a a legend in this field i
want to thank you i want to wish you a
happy early
60th birthday i cannot believe it thank
you you have done
you and i have managed to conserve
weight during covid uh you have
gotten uh more fit i have dropped five
pounds also but from my double chin
to my stomach uh i want to congratulate
you on that and first maybe that'll take
us into our first topic
do you have any daily rituals any habits
any practices that you engage in
with regularity or is every day kind of
a a
a new cause
no i have some regular habits i exercise
every morning
when it's winter i go to the gym
and lift weights and then work out on
the treadmill
and when the weather gets warmer here i
bicycle along the river yeah okay up to
the tip of manhattan and back
and where is here for my audience that
might not be familiar where are you
calling us from i'm in manhattan which
enables me to bike to the tip of
manhattan otherwise it'll be a long trip
right if you were at princeton still it
would be a little bit long but i'm sure
you could do it
uh nevertheless and what about academic
habits or
intellectual habits do you have any
daily practices anything you read on a
daily basis
writing journal anything like that
i try to keep my days
clear in the morning i'm a i'm a morning
person
so you know i'm up at six i exercise i
have a light breakfast i come in and
then
try to prepare for my day
in various ways so a lot of times
my day is meeting with graduate students
and postdocs later in the day
uh a habit i've tried to get into is
have them send me papers in advance
you know they're working on something
like the current draft the current
slides
um so i tried to spend time typically
from eight to ten um reading
uh reading what they've sent me um
reading the sometimes the scientific
literature i'll look at the archive if i
have time and see what's there
um and then the rest of my the day then
starts to
fill up um i tried to avoid
dealing with emails that are
uh just things you have to answer
uh uh you know as
the first thing i'd like to use that
time for thinking
and then i'd say what i try to do with
my day
is if i have 15 minutes between meetings
that's when i check my email and uh try
to answer it
right i mean i think it's you know we're
in this
interrupt world of email and slack
and if you want to think deeply about
things
you need to set aside blocks of time to
think
yeah and that's how you think
superficially about things you need to
set it up lots of times
yeah i've lately discovered the value of
having blank spots on my calendar but
they tend to fill up when you especially
have young kids
but uh but even more especially when you
have uh responsibilities for
for hundreds of people as you do um i
should say that currently you're at the
flatiron institute the center for
computational astrophysics
which uh as david mentioned is in
manhattan
uh before that you were a princeton
university professor for many years
you did step down you're now emeritus
professor you've won
many awards including the 2018
breakthrough prize
you won the hanuman prize and and you
honored me
by uh providing an encomium for my book
losing the nobel prize
uh which uh may may indeed hurt your
chances at one point
but you called this book the work of my
life you said
it's not often that you get to actually
touch space junk it's far removed from
your experience
but keating's book provides an ample
opportunity for tangible no you didn't
say that
you said uh very glowing things i'm very
honored that you did it you should know
i was a little nervous to provide you
with the advanced copy because as i say
i look up to you so much and i was
nervous that you know you would think
uh it was a bad idea to write this book
you didn't exactly say it was the best
idea
for this book but you did tell me some
things about prizes
and and i thought maybe we'd start there
you don't strike me as someone who's
ever been motivated to win prizes and
i've had nine nobel prize winners
on the podcast and not one of them has
ever said something like oh i was really
driven to win the nobel prize so
you know most of them are not like me as
venal and inconsequential as i am but
can you talk a little bit about prizes
you win them they don't drive you
how do you strike a balance between the
motivational aspects of fame or
attention
versus just like putting your head down
and doing the work um
yeah i mean i i was motivated to get a
job and i was certainly motivated to get
tenure and paid attention to that i
wouldn't claim to be not you know
pure purely motivated by the drive to
understand the universe you know you
want to
get a job and be able to eat and feed
your family
um but my primary
motivation is it's fun to learn stuff
and i i enjoy that i mean i think
that's one of my motivations as a mentor
it's fun to watch
people grow and develop i you know so
i think that's always been something
driving me um
you know i was right before this
uh uh call i was talking with
some students in postdocs applying
machine learning to understand
turbulence
and it is exciting to see new results
and to
be able to contribute in some way to it
now i find myself on price committees
and then you have to ask yourself what
role does a prize play
and like do you want to um reward the
person
do you want to hold the person up as an
example for younger people
as this is a model you want to follow
um you know i i think
uh for example i'm a proponent
of giving prizes to experimentalists
who put really good limits on important
numbers
we tend not to do that but i think
that's a we have
to send a message to people that careful
precision measurement
is important right i think
you know there are people who get very
upset about the idea of giving a prize
to someone
working on string theory because it's
not yet a proven theory
but regardless of whether string theory
turns out to be
an important step in the fundamental
theory of gravity
it's already taught us a lot about the
underlying structure of gravitational
physics
and you know so i think we need to
recognize
uh parts of physics or any other field
that contribute to advance
so that that to me is valuable um
i think in some ways of the prizes that
i've gotten
the one that was the most valuable to me
was the macarthur
because i got that early and
it gave me the resources
to not worry about a bunch of things i
mean the story i like to tell
is when i got my macarthur there was an
article about it in the trenton times
and i said in the interview they asked
me how will this change my life
and i said i was going to spend the
weekend cleaning the gutters
of the house but now that i have this
money
i'm going to hire someone to clean the
gutters
or physics and um
i then got an email from someone who
said
i clean gutters uh give me a call if you
want someone to clean your gutters
so i did and you know it
bought for me time which is the most
valuable thing
and also i took most of that money and
set it aside
for my kids college tuitions and remove
that source of stress
and uh so you know i think
money early that can enable you to do
things you wouldn't otherwise do
um is valuable you know
i'm i'm now moving to my new job across
the street soon
where i'm going to become president of
simon's foundation
and the foundation doesn't give out
prizes there's no simon's price
right we made a decision to do that
genetic decision to do that
because we thought it was more valuable
to take the money to fund people's
research
and one of the many things i've been
thinking about with this transition
is what are the things we can do that
will
be most effective at enabling
transformational work
you know how do we fund people when when
in their careers do we fund them and so
on
right typically prizes i talk about in
the in my book
you know the nobel prize average age has
gone up every decade by
you know faster than the rate of
inflation and now it's uh you know
recently
uh last year we had an 89 year old nurse
roger penrose your friend in mine
uh was one of the winners before that we
had people in their
80s etc and so it has gone up steadily
and it's it's almost like
by the time they receive it they almost
don't need it and sometimes they don't
make it out alive
uh as has happened uh so people don't
don't end up winning it
uh but um but yeah i agree kind of the
the unsung
uh way that that people can work without
necessarily being motivated for it and i
see a contra distinction between that i
don't know if you want to
talk about this necessarily if you don't
we can always edit it out but
oftentimes on twitter i see thing people
like us for example
you mentioned string theory one of the
um one of the self-declared
you know parents of string theory michio
kaku who i'm hoping to have on the show
in a couple weeks his new book is coming
out
it's called the god equation and the god
equation he keeps saying
we'll do what einstein didn't do so
there's an authority
um and we'll win you a nobel prize and
we'll provide you a theory of
everything that you can write in an
equation one inch
long now i know you're a master of latex
you could write in zero point font
better than anybody so the length of the
equation is irrelevant
but the conflation of einstein
and god and the nobel prize i kind of
find
that they are held up as sort of
synonymous to one another and to i
always wondered what is your perspective
on on the science as the prize of course
it's
you do it as you say um without or
expectation of reward there
thereof but um but the science as the
prize or maybe perhaps the authority
that comes with setting
the the taste or the or the preferences
of a field as string theory has
as someone like kaku is talking about
doing can you say something about that
the conflation of
of of god of of these figures of
authority of the nobel prize
along with physics i mean at first
glance they might not have
so much to do with each other
um well you know one of the things about
getting
credit or not with things it depends
what you want to accomplish
um you can
it's often been said right you can
accomplish a lot if you don't care so
much about getting credit for it
yeah lombardi said that right right yeah
i think it's
i've heard that quote uh associated with
many different people
i think ben franklin said it all right
perhaps at least i've heard it credited
to franklin um
and i think that's real that's also true
in science right there are things that
uh you know you want to accomplish that
you can
do and without getting credit and then
on the other hand
if you you do get the opportunity to do
other things and if you
uh have done
made a significant contribution and it
gets recognized it gives you
opportunities to do new things in the
future to me that's the biggest benefit
um you know the
nobel prize um
so the best use of the nobel prize to me
is someone like steve chu who won the
prize
for really you know superb work he did
then used the authority of the prize
to speak on areas like global warming
and to speak
with um
but while speaking with authority also
recognized
the weight of what he had to do so he
there are people who use the prize to be
treat themselves like authority
and talk about areas where they don't
know much mm-hmm
the halo buyers right the halo effect
and you know
um but chu became
expert on energy policy
and uh use that to to do good
um you know uh
brian schmidt uh one of our colleagues
who won the nobel prize
for his work on supernova has become an
important advocate for science uh in
australia
people like brian schmidt who've used
the prize effectively with one of my
concerns with roger penrose roger has
certainly done great work in the 70s and
80s
but he's written some fairly poor
quality papers in the last 20 years
and he's used his authority to have
press conferences
to make claims that were poorly vetted
and incorrect and the danger
about uh you know this gets to do you
want to
when you think about a prize think about
someone's
one singular contribution or think about
recognizing your career
and realizing that in giving
particularly a high profile prize like
the nobel prize
you're elevating someone to be a
spokesperson for physics
right and you've talked you've you've
certainly been on a lot of teams
and you've led teams you've also been
you know kind of member at large of
teams
now you're going to be leading the
simon's foundation as a president
in coming in is it july i think july 1st
so you know congratulations on that well
richly deserved
i want to talk about leadership and
teams um i often find
and you know i haven't been on as many
teams and projects uh
as you but uh but nevertheless i always
find that we kind of stumble into
leadership
roles and i've had conversations with
folks like barry barrish on the podcast
about leadership
and people say oh it's too hard you know
like i'm not going to learn leadership
i'm not going to learn communication or
public speaking
that's hard and i always say well you
know quantum field theory is pretty
darn hard too and i don't think you were
born knowing that uh
although although shelley glacial
basically hinted that he almost was born
knowing that
he's the only one that's been on the
show and i'll ask you this question
later too
about the imposter syndrome he's the
only person who answered in the in the
negative that he never experienced the
imposters actually frank will check also
uh but nevertheless um i'll ask you that
towards the end
but um talk about leadership and how um
we don't prioritize learning about it
and and yet it's one of our most
important
duties as a scientist as a as a mentor
and
and even on teams those of us who are on
team so uh what would you say to those
that say it's too hard to learn
you know the rules of leadership or how
to lead
i think it's a skill that can be learned
like everything else there's some people
who have innate ability to
communicate well who are
naturally born leaders but like
naturally born athletes
um you do a lot better if you train
and i think i would view leadership
like playing a sport you get better by
practice
you get better by reading about it you
get better by working with a coach
so right now you know making this
transition to becoming president of the
foundation i'm working with an executive
coach
when i became department chair when i
started to play
leadership roles and projects uh
i read books on leadership um i found
particularly useful books written by
people uh in the technology industry
because i think that's closest to what
we do we're leading teams we're
you know we're not managing our
factories we're managing groups of
people who
are making intellectual contributions to
the project
so learning uh a lot of things i think
you need to learn as a leader you need
to learn to communicate clearly
have a clear message about what you
expect of people
you want to build a team of people that
where you you bring in the brightest
people uh you have to recognize that the
brighter the people you are you wanted
people brighter than you on your team
and it's easy easy for some of us
and um you then want to make sure that
they feel comfortable speaking their
mind
and you want to make sure that people
you know you want to develop the right
culture i mean this is something i
was very conscious of when we built the
center for computational astrophysics
was
thinking about what is the intellectual
culture you want to
maintain you want to establish uh you
want people to treat each other
with respect um
you know but you also feel they can't
speak out right so you want to balance
that
and um yeah so
i i think uh leadership and mentorship
are things where we need to be trained
i think one of the failings of
the academic system is we make a
transition
from postdoc to junior faculty and
the universities don't set time aside to
say to you
all right you now need to learn pedagogy
you need to learn mentorship and
uh there there are some basic lessons
and everyone develops their own style
but there's
we can certainly learn a lot from others
and we don't train junior faculty
on making that transition you know later
in my career when i went from
a faculty member to department chair we
had
one three-hour meeting with all the new
incoming chairs where we learned
some got some basic training three hours
was good
um you know i was discussing this with
one of my
colleagues who is thinking about
becoming a dean and
we discussed that you know if i was a
dean at a university
i would want to make sure that all of my
incoming chairs
um worked with a coach had some training
on uh how do you run a department
um how do you work with your with your
faculty how do you work with your staff
how do you work with your students you
know how do you run a large organization
uh i think we've all seen departments
that have suffered
when people who are very good scientists
um and are smart people so you know uh
we can't uh all be great athletes but
you know
pretty much all of us if we're not
disabled in some way can uh run a mile
right you know speak for yourself ted
speaking well i think you know
you want to lose that clothe at 20.
i wish it was 20. god you're giving me a
head start i don't deserve
but you're absolutely right i talked to
a navy submarine commander this guy
had a 1.5 billion nuclear submarine
called the uss santa fe his name is
david marquet
uh he's been on the show and he wrote
his first book is called turn the ship
around where he took the
sub from worst to first in the navy and
different metrics and i think that was
the key in that book having metrics
because if you go into it as a scientist
you think oh scientists are naturally
driven by metrics but then
it's really like sociology as you're
saying it's a no one says
there's no one set of skills scientists
like
or professor and and uh as there is for
a baseball player i mean there you know
there might be some subtlety and some
might be more students of the game but
basically you're either pitching you're
hitting you're fielding there's a
limited more limited set of skills
but we have to deal with knowledge and
wisdom
and in his second book uh he told me the
most his second book is called
leadership
is language and in that book he said the
worst word that you can say
as a leader is right like we're gonna
launch the space shuttle today even
though the weather's uh cold right
or or like do you have any problems with
making that landing you know chuck
yeager
right um and and so i think it goes both
ways it can also be that the
the person in the in the right seat in
the plane or or the student
goes along with things that they don't
really have the
um they don't really have enough
knowledge to know that they should or
should not trust their leadership
and going back to my experience say
bicep uh there were many
many times along the way when you know i
could have stepped in i could have said
no
halt the presses you know and and i had
concerns as you know and then we talked
about that
um and were driven by papers that you
wrote with ichiro and other people
before long before the event itself
but um but i never stopped it and i
never i never said
we shouldn't land there captain you know
or we should turn the ship around
you know and and so i i think it's hard
because
as a as a student scientist you don't
really feel like you have
the ability to speak up to this
professor i mean after all
you know he or she is the chair
princeton or uc san diego or wherever
um so how do you balance that how do you
balance the like
the need for a student to to have to be
a little bit of their own
uh shepherds of their career but also
they have to trust their
their advisor their mentor it's a very
perilous dynamic also one that's never
taught nobody teaches you how to be a
grad student
a postdoc just like they don't really
teach us how to be a professor
so what would you say to a student who's
feels like something's a little bit off
but they don't have enough
kind of uh historical legacy of
knowledge to know this isn't right
well i think the first thing to do is
ask questions if you don't understand
why we're doing what the experiments
doing
it this way you're doing a theoretical
paper you don't
understand why um
i think one of the most important
phrases for
all of us to learn is i don't understand
we should never be embarrassed to say i
don't understand
you know or i'm a bit confused here can
you explain why we're doing this
and you know it probably is true nine
times out of ten
when someone explains why they're doing
it they're doing it for a good reason
um and if you're part of a paper and you
want to understand
and you're reading as a co-author and
you don't understand why we're doing
this if you don't know you know i like
to tell people if you don't understand
it
a lot of other people don't understand
the reader's not gonna
right you should make it as easy as
possible so i think for a student you
want to be asking questions
right you know why are we making this
assumption and so on
and every now and then you ask that
question and it's like
i don't know why we're doing this why
don't we make this assumption
um you know and
uh this tends to be i feel at this point
uh you know how i contribute to
science in my discussions right it's
like you know
someone um this is why i mentioned early
on when you talked about my daily habits
how i like to have
students sometimes send me in advance a
write-up of what they've done
and i like to if as i look at it i ask
like why are you making these
assumptions
and for me that's uh i think
often the way i can contribute most to
the project
is is asking questions and trying to
understand what
you know understanding for myself forces
me to um to ask questions
and then you know i people like to say
there's
you know no such thing as a dumb
question
and that really is mostly true i mean
there's questions you ask because you're
simply not paying attention
or you haven't done the re you know uh
you haven't done the homework
right you missed the previous four
lectures that explained what that is
right that those questions you might
want to
at least look over the notes but most of
the time if you don't understand
something
um you want to ask those questions and i
think
uh a piece of leadership is
encouraging that encouraging people to
ask questions and
creating environments where they can do
that
there are some tricks i've learned um to
get people to ask questions and speak
more
right just go around the room you know
you make sure that
rather than just having the loudest
voice heard
uh you try to hear from all voices
especially under represented voices i
find that a lot now with my students who
come from
traditionally under represented
backgrounds in in physics
um african-american uh students or
female in in science and even in
leadership positions david there are
people that you and i know very well
and sometimes i'll be in a meeting i'm
like you're so much wiser and smarter
than me
but you're not speaking up let me let me
just be a boris you know stupid
mansplainer
and just ask what do you think you know
to to to one of these
one of our colleagues and i'll be
surprised i'm just like god if you
didn't answer like i'll hurt myself
patting myself on the back but only for
asking them
please tell me what you think because i
think it can really be dangerous not to
not to do what you just said go around
the room yeah no you want to hear
everyone's voice
and um i i think
when you're the only woman in the room
you're the only
african-american you know and even if
you're just
you know we all have had moments maybe
not frank we'll check i guess
where you mentioned where we feel
inadequate we feel we don't know enough
uh and we feel awkward asking questions
um you know i'm
i'm finding myself uh again in this
situation which is i think refreshing
and growing right because
now that i'm becoming president of a
foundation that works on things like
autism
what do i know about autism what do i
know about neuroscience
um everyone else in the room knows more
than me
and you know i know i'm inadequate in
this but on
the other hand i need to learn and i'll
only learn by asking questions
and i would say nine out of my ten
questions um are questions
you know of someone who's ignorant and
learning
they're not dumb they're ignorant
questions had i studied the field
but every now and then you come into an
area and you ask a question
and it turns out to actually be an
interesting question
because you think about things
differently from other people
right and i think that you know having
that taste developing that taste it
takes some confidence and confidence is
built on
you know some level of past success but
but certainly you know failure you know
i did a google engram search once and it
was like what
if you if you hear the following words
it was the best thing
that ever happened to me and you asked
google what
two words or the most commonly used
before those words
it was the best thing that ever happened
to me it turns out it's i failed or
i got fired you know in my case i had
both you know experiences in my life
um and it was the best experience like i
wouldn't be talking to you i wouldn't i
don't know what i'd be doing
without failure so ironically we think
of our successes
as you know as as building this this
great capability and capacity it's more
often than not our failures
and it's just amazing that you know
someone who presumably hasn't failed all
that much
uh has done so much and succeeded so
much so maybe you know it's
as pilots say you have to learn from the
from the failures about hogwarts because
you won't live long enough to make them
all yourself
[Music]
i do think actually some of my most
important work came out of
in a sense failures right so i
i spent about four years
working on the idea that topological
defects cosmic strings
textures sort of defects produced at
phase transitions
could be the source of large scale
structure and we
wrote a bunch of papers on this and
i understood it well enough to
understand the predictions of the model
um i would argue in retrospect that's
actually a success exploring a model and
realizing its predictions
is is a good thing but you know when the
new data came in from kobe which is the
first measurements the microwave
background as you know well
um our bottle was dead i knew it was
ruled out
and you know i did not
respond to that result with joy
you know when you've worked on something
for four years and the data rules it out
that's not a happy moment no um
on the other hand um
it made me rethink where things were
going
it actually made me appreciate how
quickly the microwave background was
going to get interesting
so i then decided to start thinking
about what the microwave background can
tell us
about the basic properties of the
universe it's geometry it's composition
and so on
and that eventually led to a series of
papers that provided
the science case for document right so
i would say the failures of those four
years going in the wrong direction
in a sense led to the successes that
followed in the subsequent years
right yeah and in fact i had on john
mather last month
on the podcast and he was talking you
know he's much more a matter of fact i
think um
but the experience of the challenger
disaster setting back kobe
and just like introducing complete
uncertainty
uh as we scientists like to say you know
if you don't write down the uncertainty
associated with some
answer that you get you can't uh you
can't really say you
understand it uh in in full breath uh
completely i want to talk about a quote
that i often think about with regard to
you
in in in regards to pedagogy etc
which is um attributed to uh somebody i
believe it was the laboratory rebbe the
the
rabbi of the chabad movement back in the
early part of the mid part of the 1900s
and he said he said a good leader
creates many followers but a great
leader creates many
leaders and i wonder if we can talk
about um
the the leadership philosophy you're
very famous and well known
for saying the main thing students need
is love
what do you mean by that they need a
sense of self-confidence
they need a sense of support
um you know i think
as a parent your goal is to
first teach your kids the basic skills
but then give them the confidence to go
out on their own and find their own path
and i think that's the same thing we
want to do
as mentors you know we do need to teach
our students
some basic skills but more important
than the basic skills
is the self-confidence to succeed
and um you know when i've
said that um about students needing love
that's actually a quote
from um denis shama all right
let's go dennis shama was the mentor
of uh stephen hawking
uh roger penrose um
martin reese martin uh martin reese the
baron of ludlow
that's her astronomer royal who tells
the queen her horoscope every morning
exactly um james benny one of my mentors
a lot of people studied with
denis shama interestingly
dennis shaman never got a professorship
at cambridge
because at the time there was a feeling
there were too many jews who had
professorships already
so but he had a tremendous effect on the
field
some through his work but primarily
through his students
and my uh one of my
uh collaborators graciela romini
graciela
and i worked together when we were both
at harvard
had gone to sisa in trieste
where um sharma was now a professor
and she asked him as a starting
assistant professor
uh what do students need and it was
dennis who said
this to graciela and graciela told me
this
and what dennis said was if you give
students a sense of love a sense of
self-confidence
they'll find an interesting project
they'll have the confidence to find an
interesting project or have a confidence
to do interesting work
and you know you don't want to give
people
false feedback they come in with poor
quality work and you say
that's wonderful because they know that
people know it on the other hand you do
want to
uh encourage people to
take those next steps um
and you know uh
encourage people to realize like you
know if you don't succeed try try again
and then if that fails take a different
approach um
that's so funny you mentioned that's
exactly what uh what john mather said he
said
you know it's okay to have heterodox
views maybe even
crank views uh alternative views but
only so far
you know at some point you have to be
able to falsify
your hypothesis or whatever even if it
is heterodox and we're all for diversity
of viewpoint right
um but um but that leads me into my next
set of questions and that's
related to the baron that you just
mentioned lord martin reece who on my
show
we we talked about we talked about the
value of debate
in science and he said uh and i quote
to me most of debate is pointless
because people don't really change their
minds
and um and it can actually create an
illusion
of of uncertainty or perhaps give equal
weight to a very very much minority
viewpoint not you know obviously in a
battle but
um and you and you participated very
graciously on the great debate
you know redux that we did on the 100th
anniversary of the great debate
uh shapley curtis debate and uh we had a
great conversation
uh but you know as as fun as that was
with adam reece and sarah seeger
wendy friedman jen 11 and you and me
um you know we didn't we didn't i get
that much out of it actually i'll have a
link because i made an e-book
which i'll send to you uh an illustrated
ebook from that event
which is available for all my
subscribers so please subscribe to my
mailing list briankeating.com you'll get
a copy of that
david's words were very uh fascinating
but anyway
what about debate are there people you
won't debate so to speak i mean
obviously someone who
has you know negative you know bad
intentions but are there viewpoints i
mean would you
debate somebody i recently had someone
on who uh is a very well known
cambridge university trained doctor of
philosophy
uh who's an intelligent design proponent
he's not a young earth creationist
would you or will you talk to anybody as
long as they have you know
pure motives or do you feel like martin
does it's not worth it
i think it depends on the person um i
think
you're very rarely going to convince the
other person
in a debate right i mean i
you know you can get i i think about
this with facebook
um can you point out someone who has
been convinced
of of another political view by reading
something on facebook
i i i'm not familiar with this
phenomenon
politics right i mean how many people
have no that's what i mean politics
politics that's right um on the other
hand
um there are people who listen to these
debates who come in with open mind
so it depends on the forum
there's a balance where if it's a
discussion of something like intelligent
design
is by engaging in this discussion is
this an opportunity
to convey to
an interested but not scientifically
literate audience
why we actually have a very good
scientific why evolution really
represents by far the best model we have
so you know um and
uh
and you know sometimes
you know i i engaged in a debate once
with this guy who wrote a book that the
the big bang never happened
and um was that jeff burbidge here at uc
san diego no
no it was just you know in fact i
remember
when jeff burbidge came to princeton to
give a colloquium
and i was an undergraduate
and martin schwartshield one of my
heroes
was sitting in the front row as martin
often did
and asked a series of pointed questions
and martin turned to me afterwards and
said the reasons i ask these questions
is for you
that as a student you should realize
the weaknesses in these arguments so
for me the reason to engage the debate
if
uh is if there's going to be students
listening
who will um not understand the
weaknesses
of those arguments yeah and i often feel
i say this and
and i did a video about this around the
presidential debates
you know i feel like it's almost you
know we should look to the scientific
way of debating
again the way that shapley and curtis
debated eventually you know
shapley came around it took some
evidence to to
convince him which is which is fine but
he was convince a bull from the outset
in other words
if the evidence had existed if the data
were good enough as einstein did
einstein debate as you know better than
me
um the validity of the big bang model
and then he saw data the evidence uh
convinced him but if you're not in
principle
possibly falsifiable in your tenants or
what you believe
whether it's political or whatever i i
do agree that a lot of it is pointless
but you're right i hadn't considered
that notion of of um you know the
benefits
let me give you two examples of people
who have been on your show
okay so adam reese
adam is trying to convince people that
there really is strong evidence
that local measurements the hubble
constant um give a large value
uh and cons wendy friedman uses another
method
and argument argues for a different
value yep
they both um fundamentally
are most interested in getting at the
answer
and when later this year the james webb
space telescope launches
hopefully launch goes well deploy
successful we will have a telescope
far more powerful than hubble and
it will measure distances to
uh the nearby uh galaxies
and it will get those distances more
accurately than hubble
and um i think that data
could easily convince wendy
or me that adam is completely right the
data improves and that just gets more
and more solid
on the other hand uh it could show that
blending for cepheids is
more of a problem and more complicated
within ways we thought and some
subtle things are going on and adam will
be convinced
so that's a scientific debate where
people will respond to evidence
um i am not convinced that your recent
gastavi lobe was um
is actually interested in what a maya
mayor is
rather than wants to promote the idea
that he's seen aliens
i think that the response to claims
like this could be easily explained by
a solid nitrogen much like what we see
on the surface of pluto is a much
simpler
and more plausible explanation and uh
you know we're we're seeing discussions
that are about selling books
not about trying to understand the way
the universe works
well i i have to defend him a little bit
uh just just to make it interesting for
the i thought you were going to bring up
roger penrose
or giant narlikar who was a guest about
a month ago
uh who is still not convinced of the
validity of the big bang model
uh but he's impossible to not love him
he's such a gentleman
and anyone you know who is you know so
close to fred hoyle
uh there's got to be some good good uh
good natured fun to be had with that
person but let's
talk about avi so i agree with you that
i don't believe that avi
believes what he's claiming but for a
completely different reason and that is
um i said to him avi uh you you know if
only you knew a billionaire
you know that could fund a research
voyage to omuamua
let's let's not talk about these objects
coming in the future that you think will
be discovered with the vera rubin uh
observatory
or maybe with jb wst or what have you by
the way
that's going to be based on just sheer
number of engram searches on the into
the impossible podcast
that telescope is not going to have one
second of downtime sarah sieger was
telling me
how much she's looking forward to using
it now you know we're hearing all these
different things avi wants to
so uh but getting back to avi i said why
instead of sending
a bunch of you know iphone uh four
cameras to proxima centauri b
why don't you just get yuri your buddy
uh milner to
uh to sponsor by the way he sponsored
your breakthrough prize if i'm not
mistaken
um and he's a very very important figure
i think in in modern science but anyway
get him to send a cubesat to a muammual
before it go you know it's still it's
not traveling nearly the speed of light
that your cameras are gonna have to get
close to
and he said no no no brian don't worry
there if i'm right there be plenty of
umumua-like objects coming
uh and veer rubin will observe them and
i'll be well
and i said you know look if i had uh if
i believed that
that this was true i wouldn't stop at
any there's nothing i would stop at
to validate my theory and i said to him
you're you're being accused of of
you know trying to get popular attention
going on you know the joe rogan show and
whatnot i don't have anything against it
by the way
because i do think science should be
popularized and i think the
it's natural that somebody talks about
aliens and alien technology is going to
be lumped together with
with the with the kooks right but yeah
i think you're saying something i think
there's a standard of proof for
important claims
right and you know before you resort to
and make large public announcements
about important revolutionary claims
the claim ought to be widely vetted and
you want you know
and um that doesn't mean i mean i think
it's very appropriate to think about
these things
right uh he's written like 80 papers
about it's not you know that oh here's
a book um obviously the book got him a
lot of attention but you know and
also well but i think that you know the
you know there's a
i'm not sure that the uh ideas of other
people
have been treated with the respect they
deserve by
yeah and that's certainly true there's a
well-known incident where he was
uh very very um
you know he he was acting very um
someone who has devoted her career to
doing
yeah yeah
who's you know uh to go back to
something we talked about
uh earlier i have a lot of admiration
for people like jill who devote a lot of
energy for doing really hard things
yeah one of the greatest compliments i
ever got uh was uh
in addition to your incoming on my book
but jill read it and not only did she
read it
um the day before it was due she was
going to give a talk or press conference
and one of my friends at the seti
institute had to pick her up to go give
the talk
and he arrived at her house in berkeley
and she was all disheveled and
and she didn't have her makeup on her
hair whatever looks you know looks
whatever like i do every day but you
know she's she cleans up very
beautifully
and uh and he said she said i was up all
night reading this darn book
and it was my book and uh she gave it
she gave an incoming she's been a guest
on the show as well and she's the clown
she's you know like she's she's the the
chuck yeager
on the west coast shall we say of
astrophysics as the person you want to
emulate
cool under fire just a scientist
scientist at every level
but um but yeah so so these
controversies come up and avi in his
book
is very dismissive of things like the
multiverse and this is why i pressed him
on it i said
we might not be able to falsify the
multiverse right because it could be
that there are multiverses there are
other universes we don't have access to
them
and we have a mutual you know uh disdain
for for kind of
physics that can't be necessarily tested
but i said avi
you could test omumua's alien origin by
visiting
literally visiting it unlike another
universe which we can't probably even
in and practice visit so i want to ask
you though about these kind of
unfalsifiable things i talked to john
prescott
sorry to drop so many names he's the
richard feynman professor
at caltech a little technical college up
the road you don't spend any time in
california anymore
i really miss you coming out here but um
but next next time you're here
you know that i i i was hoping to get
there this thing called code that
happened
what kobe haven't heard yeah yeah yeah
is that intelligent design
is that co-variant intelligent design
actually a very interesting question
is what is the origin of covet not
something i'm expert on at all
right yeah there is an interesting
debate
on its origin yes so uh but getting back
to
uh john preschool so i said um because
he uh was friends with stephen hawking
famously and
and and they had many bets and one of
the things that he was most interested
in is inflation and
and also how the early universe is
evolving in addition to quantum
computing which was the subject of our
conversation
but i uh at one point i said you know
because he's talking about string theory
and uh and your friend of mine comrade
another guest
when i ask you at the end of the show
i'm gonna ask you what um
what information would you put on a
billion-year-long lasting time capsule
and qumran said the equations of string
theory and i said to
i said to john i said what about what
would feynman say about that feynman is
famous for saying
i don't care how beautiful your theory
is i don't care what
kind of equations they predict uh unlike
dirac if it doesn't agree with
experiment it's wrong
but david what about things you can't
experiment on
do they count as wrong or right or john
just said try
harder which i found a little
unsatisfying what do you think about
things you can't even in principle test
uh via experiment are they not even
wrong as paulie
i think palliative would say well
i think so string theory is an
interesting example
so uh if we
in principle um you could imagine
uh we understood which we do not yet how
string vacuors
selected and we knew uh
a way of predicting uh
fundamental constants we could predict
the const
the constants of the standard model from
string theory
that would be a tremendous success as
it's
nowhere near not we my colleagues or
colleagues working this or no one hear
this yet
not only that they could predict not
just
those constants but the properties of
something like dark matter would drop
out of the theory
and then be confirmed by experiment i
think we'd all look at that and say
wow that was a success
if that were to happen and we then
understood string theory at a level
where we said
um it predicted the multiverse
um which i don't you know uh then i
think we would be forced to take
the idea of multiverses uh
more seriously as an interesting and
untestable outcome
of this theory that seems to be a good
description of nature
that we've tested in other ways so you
know i could see a path
where um i would take multi-verses
seriously
at this point until we have you know
i our ability to understand them are
limited by
things we definitely have no access to
what's the right prior for initial
conditions for the universe
i don't think it's an interesting
discussion i think this got you know
when i look at
areas of physics a question i ask myself
is is am i investing my time or now that
i'm
president of a foundation that supports
basic research um
are our investing resources in this
likely to advance the field
in the next 20 30 years or not even
likely have a chance of advancing the
field
um and um
you know the
i think string theory is uh
to me is an interesting bet i've been
very
impressed by the recent work that came
out of techniques people learned by
string theory
but doesn't actually rest itself on
string theory
on understanding um the information
paradox with black holes
i think there's been a lot of progress
on that in the last couple years and
that's a profound question um that
really has been
um the ideas that have come out of
people thinking about string theory has
really helped advance that we wouldn't
have done that without that
so i think there are some real advances
coming
from string theory um on the other hand
um i've seen
most of the work i've seen on
multiverses um
is to me not that interesting and not
that likely to
lead to uh insight of course i could be
wrong
yeah right that's you know we replace
our bets
we bet you know and we place our bets
most fundamentally with our time
that's right although yeah lately i've
been thinking about uh
in the context of kids you know you see
they say as you said you know the most
important resource is
time it's true i mean although we watch
enough cat videos at least around here
to be put that to the test but
my feeling is actually innocence is the
most uh
irredeemable a non-fungible form of
resource
because really once you lose your
innocence whatever that means it could
be
i've talked to soldiers after they came
back from going to war and
actually ending the lives of other
people they had to do it or they would
have been
their lives would have been ended um and
and you know you look at
what can you get back um and i think
with research yeah there are so many
dollars and and
when you think about your portfolio how
are you going to risk balance [ __ ] how
are you going to hedge it i love talking
to jim about the simon's observatory
getting back to uh where you're who
you're going to be replacing and it's
good he's finally retiring
i i hope he'll have enough to live off
of in retirement
uh but uh but jim always said you know
if we detect
inflationary generated uh b modes with
uh primordial perturbations using the
simon's observatory
we'll be dancing in the streets and
we'll win a nobel prize however if we
don't
that might even be more interesting it
might you know cast uh have theological
or philosophical
implications uh the last kind of
personal question or sort of scientific
question
per semi-personal question before we
close out
uh with the three questions i ask
everybody like how much
does what you do matter to you in that
you obviously are very accomplished you
could do anything
and i think a lot of our colleagues and
the students that you've you've turned
into faculty all around the world they
could do anything they could be ceos
they could be
um you know hedge fund uh traders as jim
might have them um but how much what you
do do you feel
matters and the ultimate questions i
know you're a very uh philosophical
person
um i know that you um that you're very
knowledgeable about about religion
theology etc what do you think is the is
the is the value of a life and science
like this
and and does it give you meaning can
knowledge in other words science means
knowledge not wisdom
but but has it brought a sense of wisdom
to you or a sense of wonder
what what metaphysical um satisfaction
do you get if any i'm not sure
if you do from what you do as a as a
scientist
um i believe in
the scientific enterprise i think it
one of humanity's great accomplishments
and certainly one of the great
accomplishments of the last few hundred
years
has been our deepening understanding of
the universe
and by that i don't just mean cosmology
i mean everything from
you know the biology and anthropology
and the whole
broad sweep of of science we
we understand more now than we did in
the past
and we have
um
done something that well some of the
outcomes of science
and increased knowledge has led to
technologies that have
made life worse in many ways
life for humanity is better a smaller
fraction of the human population goes to
bed hungry now
than ever in our history right i think
there
are uh more people
are free uh in various ways there's
a hell of a lot of inequality but
there's a lot more equality than there
was in the middle ages
right we the world is a better place and
i think some of that is the advance of
science
and i feel fortunate to be able to
contribute
in a number of different ways to
advancing science some through my own
work
perhaps in the long run i think my
greatest contributions will be through
training students
right that there's a i've had the good
fortune to train
you know probably of what are 100 people
who have been my graduate student or
post-doc or undergrad
many of whom have done really exciting
work
and the fact that i've helped train them
and contribute to them
to me means i'm helping to contribute to
science
so um so for me
uh contributing to our understanding
is one of the things that gives meaning
to life
very good david thank you very much for
that and now we're going to enter the
into the impossible thrilling three if
you have a few more minutes david
will you bear with us okay great so but
to get david's answers you're going to
have to subscribe to
this channel dr ryan keating on uh on
youtube and then you can also subscribe
on itunes or stitcher or spotify
wherever you get
podcasts bought and sold podcasts are
free but your time
is is valuable and i appreciate every
listener
david spurgle um may you reach the
biblical age maybe exceed it with the
developments and breakthroughs that the
simons foundation will undoubtedly come
to under your
stewardship i wish you uh blessings of
we are one of the things we're funding
is a program called the plasticity of
the aging brain
wow oh that's phenomenal
so and one of the things
to get back to something you asked at
the very beginning
that i think we're learning
is that just having good blood flow
to the brain helps so
get out get out and start to get out and
start running in the morning
or get on that get on that peloton
that's right
i gotta i gotta i gotta get the laundry
off of it first that's that's always the
biggest obstacle
um david uh we love you uh we're richard
for knowing you
uh you're a blessing in our lives as
cosmologists as
as scientists and just as students of
the universe
i wish you great luck a happy birthday
and i hope that you'll come back again
on the into the impossible podcast i
look forward to it and uh i look forward
to
when the world is traveling comfortably
and come out and
visit san diego see you out there i hope
so and i hope to see you in new york
city and i i miss my ancestral homeland
david b always welcome
[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
[Music]
you